bougez plus l'achat voilà on se calme un
problème au pas de problème d'accord qui
es-tu star lord star quoi star lord
enfin legrand la loi et ce temps on les
a arrêtés tous les 5 sur 15 ans d'art et
ils ont un pedigree drax alias le
destructeur depuis que sa femme et toute
sa famille ont été tués ils écument la
galaxie pour assouvir sa soif de
vengeance camorra soldats assassin
recherché pour une dizaine de meurtres
rock est recherché pour 55 vols de
divers véhicules évasion mais qu'est ce
que c'est que ça bottes et voyages avec
rocket pour qu'il fait office de plantes
vertes et de gardes du corps
peter jason quid aussi connu sous le nom
de star lors qui lui a donné un nom
pareil et s'est trouvé tout seul il est
recherché entre autres pour coups et
blessures
ivresse sur la voie publique et
escroquerie oh pardon j'ai pu contrarier
cette machine malgré moi et c'est à moi
ils se font appeler les gardiens de la
galaxie
quelle bande de dégénérés
mathieu
la wii